foreign
I gotta say the the first experience I
had with a great white or I should say
the lead up to the first experience was
filled with Terror that's National
Geographic Explorer Gibbs kaguru Gibbs
is a Kenyan scientist who studies sharks
and he's talking about the first time he
dove with great whites he's on the coast
in South Africa I was certain I was
going to die I was like yeah I'm in this
situation you know the sea looks a bit
choppy it's gray skies which is by the
way perfect Sharky conditions and I'm
about to get into cage like I'm
basically like a gummy bear for this
this you know two-ton animal and I I put
the wetsuit on and I remember just
staring over the edge of the boat into
the cage and thinking you know this is
this is what my coffin's gonna look like
and
and as soon as you see your first great
white
you're I shouldn't say you're my
imagination about them being these
bloodthirsty man-eaters immediately
dissipated
because
you saw a curious beautiful
Fierce uh graceful animal just you know
enjoying its surroundings there was no
malice or inspired cruelty to its
actions and you could see that and I I
always tell people that or they're like
man it must be scary going out to to
work every day and I'm like no way like
once you see what I've seen
you'll never have that you know weird
notion that these sharks are anything
less but just beautiful animals in the
wild
I'm Peter Gwynn editor at large at
National Geographic and you're listening
to overheard a show where we eavesdrop
on the wild conversations we have here
at naggio and follow them to the edges
of our big weird beautiful world
this week we meet a guy who went off to
swim with sharks because well he didn't
know what he was going to do with his
life and in the process he fell in love
with these misunderstood wild creatures
he'll tell us why they drew him in what
it's like to free dive with sharks and
what genetics can tell us about these
ancient ocean animals
more after the break
fuel your curiosity with a free
one-month trial subscription to Nat Geo
digital you'll have unlimited access on
any device anywhere ad free with our app
that lets you download stories to read
offline explore every page ever
published with a century of digital
archives at your fingertips check it all
out for free at Nat geo.com
Explore More
[Music]
can you sort of
paint that scene of the first time you
actually put on scuba gear and went and
dived with sharks
I was doing this Pre-Med program and uh
I didn't love it to be honest and my
study advisor at the time was like I
know you don't love it and he knew I was
not really going to go anywhere with it
um so he sends me this bulletin to come
dive with sharks in South Africa this
thing that your professor saw what was
it exactly was it like a a research
project or was it like a tour company or
what what was it yeah it was a tour
company that took clients out every day
to see great whites you know you stick
them in the cage they see a whole bunch
of great whites and they leave you know
having their lives absolutely changed
and I thought that was a crazy idea
sharks to me appeared to be one of the
most dangerous things on the planet but
at that stage in my life I was sort of
confronted with two types of fear the
first was continuing on with this
program that I was discont tented with
deeply for the rest of my life and the
second one was get eaten alive
potentially by great white which is you
know the fear of death but long story
short I chose the Sharks I chose to Dawn
the wetsuit and get in the water because
for me the the fear of losing a life
well lived was Far scarier than losing
life itself and being in the water with
sharks
um gave me a whole world of new
possibilities that I could thrive in and
and love is is I also found love for
sharks and yeah
I I can't describe it any other way
because I remember the first moment I
got a chance to step away from doing
shark work I I felt like my world was
crumbling and I I don't see it going any
other way I think I can I want to do
this for as long as I'm physically
capable
well okay so that's man that's super
dramatic so go from you know preparing
to take you know the the Medical
entrance exams versus
going to dive with sharks so okay so
what happens you get on a plane and I
mean how do you even begin this process
diving with sharks yeah I mean the first
thing was you know improve my competency
in the water uh which meant learning how
to dive learning how to boat and then
also being comfortable uh in a variety
of situations with wild animals and and
that's that's something that I feel like
uh is is definitely a skill but there's
also an intuition about you know
figuring out how an animal thinks works
and you know it also plays into how safe
you can be around them
um and this is this is all just comes
with like time and experience
um and six years working at a shark
diving company
um was the crash course that I needed to
get me to the level where I can be a
confident shark scientist
uh and then I was an intern there uh for
six months and you know after that six
months like I said I I had an
opportunity to to walk back and go and
take my medical school entry exam and I
was like hell no I'm not gonna do that
uh put me in the water again man like I
I I just I couldn't imagine not doing
that it's one of those things where
I don't really remember what life was
like before I saw my first great white
it was just seeing great whites and then
I'm like yep that's it so how did you
get from that into the research part
into the into the sort of the academic
world of sharks
yeah I felt uh uninspired with my
Pre-Med program
um and for the first time in my life I I
had Wonder again and that's what pushed
me to be like okay I have these sharks
and I have maybe some academic curiosity
can I marry these two things together
and you know learn as much as I can
about these animals
so what was it like the first time that
you
weren't inside a cage when you went down
to study sharks
what did that feel like I mean I know
you you you said that you you got this
sense of like
you since they're not the creatures that
we've imagined them to be through your
experience with the tour company but
then when you actually get outside the
safety of the cage what does that feel
like
being in the water with sharks is
is it's an out of body experience you
feel like you're being watched and
you're sort of you're sort of watching
yourself being watched by these animals
and it's freeing at the same time
because it feels like you're suspended
in air and there's these things just
floating around you just observing you
and most of the time uh they don't even
stick around because you're really not
that interesting to them
um as far as like a food source goes so
they come out they check you out they're
like oh what is this really weird lanky
thing floating in in my environment uh
they check you out for a little bit and
then they they Dart off and and those
are the moments that make me sad
actually because I'm like man I want to
see this thing as much as possible
um how do I get it around me and and
this is why I continue doing what I do
is because that moment when the shark
swims away from from me is like man okay
I need to come back tomorrow and do this
again so I can spend that much more time
with it just to see what it does
sharks are such a a topic of
conversation in the United States and
you know we can talk a little bit about
the Jaws effect but if you know Jaws
came out and really colored a lot of
people's view of of sharks in the United
States well what do people in Kenya
like growing up what was the attitude
was there a similar sort of like
perception of them you know I think that
you're you're touching on something
important there with the Jaws effect and
I think the impact of that film
permeated just about every corner of
society because even growing up in you
know Nairobi which is nowhere near the
ocean I was under the impression that
sharks are dangerous and I had this
notion going growing up for my entire
childhood even when we went to the beach
for the holidays it was always like
don't go out too far because they're
gonna get you
yeah right so that's become a universal
phenomenon I guess the the monster in
the ocean that's lurking out there I
think people need to hear more inspiring
shark stories
um unfortunately we had one movie that
changed the scope of sharks PR for
Generations
um I think people were sort of inclined
to having a fear about things they don't
understand but when that fear was given
a face in a name Jaws that immediately
solidified that in our psyche as you
know the thing we have to avoid at all
costs and if we can't avoid it then we
have to kill it and that's just what
people do when we feel vulnerable we we
want to make sure that there's no way in
the future where we'll ever feel
threatened again
and This spells the end not just for
sharks but for a healthy working
environment which is is what we need too
can you kind of you know for the for the
person listening that doesn't you know
know a lot about this could you kind of
walk us through the evolutionary history
of sharks
um yeah so based on we know what we know
from their genetic history we see that
they predate trees and that means
they've been around for eras
um
I had no idea older than trees yeah wow
what that tells me is that you know
these animals are so perfectly designed
they've been around through eras of of
mass extinctions and that's that is is
so remarkable especially when we look at
what's happening today when their
populations are being forced to adapt to
humans and bounce back from the brink of
Extinction you know and and like I said
humans are the primary cause that's
that's making these animals that have
been around for millennia
you know be at risk of Extinction well
well tell me a little bit about the
impact that humans are having on sharks
I mean I I take it it's more than one
it's multifaceted is there is there any
one particular area of this crisis that
you've looked at the work that I'm doing
in the Maldives is is really based on
learning about the direct human impacts
on shark populations
um
over about a 40 or 50 year period people
had fished the Maldives out nearly to a
population collapse
and then the Sharks bounced back
we thought that it was going to be all
fine but now these sharks are coming
back with a skin disease essentially and
it's it it looks kind of like spots that
you'd get from uh like just you know
like a sunspot almost like where where
you just lose the ability to create
pigment
which is you know sharks have melon and
pigment just like we do which is
actually kind of cool
um but they lose this ability and this
Gene that codes for melanin pigment is
linked to so many other functions uh in
the in the shark's body as well as ours
that it's potentially giving them other
deformations as far as their development
goes so what what's the sort of the the
answer to that I mean is there some you
know have you guys isolated a specific
sort of cause for that that can be
addressed or
um again and this goes back to that
whole complexity of nature
um
if you break it it's really difficult to
put back together the way it was and and
over time we've realized that
conservation is is so vital not just
from a let's see how many animals we
have but we need to have a diverse array
of animals and I know the term diversity
gets thrown around a lot
um and it's in the context of you know
diverse people diverse ideas but when
we're talking about genetic diversity
we're really talking about the strength
that binds populations together and
without diversity you eventually breed
in weakness and that's what these sharks
are sort of dealing with now is we've
just we've we've
shrunken their gene pool to a gene
puddle and there's not that many genes
that can help their potential of
survival and they're yeah then you come
out with sharks that have spots that
aren't able to protect themselves from
harmful UV rays and a Litany of other
problems one of the things I've heard is
that you'd studied um
about how great white sharks can change
their color I'd never heard that before
man that is crazy how does that work
so I first heard about sharks changing
color from my employer when I worked in
at the cage diving company and I
remember thinking that was the craziest
thing I've ever heard because
um we saw the same shark but I didn't
see it change color but he could he
would swear by it
um then I went to visit other cage
diving companies and they said the same
thing
um again me being the skeptic I thought
it was some kind of industry joke that I
just wasn't in on and uh as we kept
going I started realizing that maybe
there is something to this so we just
devised an experiment to expose this and
we being myself and Ryan Johnson my
mentor
um but we essentially found that great
whites do have this ability to modulate
their color to be better suited in their
environment and there are
um certain situations where they need to
be camouflaged to hunt better maybe be
camouflaged to defend themselves from a
larger Predator like an orca in their
environment and they'll you know go down
to the bottom of the ocean where the
colors are a lot more muted and they go
pale so there's there's all that there's
this interplay of using their skin to to
be better predators and also a less
viable prey
man that is crazy one of the other
things I'd heard is that they can really
heal themselves
that they have this ability to sort of
regenerate uh quickly after they've been
injured or
sick
yeah we've seen this happen uh quite a
number of times with our sharks
um you know on any given day you'll see
a great white with this most Grievous
wound out of its side and you think oh
there's no way this thing is going to
recover from that like an entire chunk
of its flesh was removed
and you watch this shark go around your
boat over time and then within a year
it's like it was never hurt you know
it's like it had never experienced this
trauma and what we've also learned
through genetics is that these sharks
actually have genes that are geared
towards this adaptive immunity that
essentially gives them you know like a
super power like Wolverine where you
know they can take anything
um physically damaging and recover from
it and I think that is one of the the
coolest discoveries about shark
adaptations and it even has biomedical
implications because we can potentially
you know isolate genes like that and use
you know things like gene therapy to
um assist people who need to you know
I'm just spitballing here like regrow
limbs or recover from cancers the
applications are endless but you know we
just need to do more research to find
out how we can actually use you know
this ancient anime
uh to fix us which is cool
[Music]
what's the thing that surprised you the
most during your time working with
sharks has there been anything that just
like blew your mind like wait I mean
you've already kind of listed a few a
few that have been blown my mind but is
there any like shark behavior or
or in a specific encounter where you
were like wow I I totally didn't expect
that yeah I will say the thing that
surprised me the most about sharks was
uh learning about shark social networks
um and this was during a very difficult
trial I had when I was working in the
Maldives and I was trying to get tissue
samples
um for my PhD study which I'm currently
doing so I went and found the the
juiciest freshest bloodiest tuna that I
could find which anything by sea or land
would go crazy for it's good eating
um so I set this Tuna on a hook
um and you know laid it out in an area
where I know these black tip reef sharks
would occur
and for two months I watched every day
one of these sharks observed my bait and
turn away you know this was the most
delicious meal that I could have
prepared for them because it's highly
you know it's it's a nice oily fish it's
highly nutritious and like I said any
animal on sea at sea or land would would
go crazy for it
um and yeah like any chef
um who's prepared a delicious meal
um I became very despondent you know I
asked myself why are these sharks not
taking the bait and as it turns out
these sharks are a lot smarter than they
look and it was for sure not very
difficult for them to outsmart me
um which I took by the way very
personally
um and the reason for this uh the
surprising thing is that these sharks
actually have a cohesive social network
that allows them to identify threats in
their environment and then collectively
avoid them and interestingly these
sharks have seen fishing gear before
they're a historically overfished
population so they see me a scientist
coming in with the same fishing gear
that a fisherman has used and they know
that is danger
and there's actually a really
interesting paper about about this
written by Johann murir based out in
French Polynesia
we know that these sharks are doing this
the crazy thing is we just don't know
how how do they communicate
um in any case through that trial I I
licked my wounds I called my buddy
Walker and who by the way is a
world-class Waterman we got a whole
bunch of equipment devised a plan and
then we successfully managed to catch
these sharks
um through that you know my ego took a
really big hit because I've been working
with great whites you know and these
little black tips had managed to you
know you know play me for a fool
um it taught me a lot of new crucial
skills but one very important lesson I
learned is that I actually I don't know
Yeah the more you learn the more you
realize you have to learn right yeah
um I saw I saw what was happening to my
sharks
you know it it these animals which I I
loved so dearly were taking such a hit
from people and
it it almost it made me feel a little
bit helpless
because the the love that I had for them
was was not backed by action
uh and that's that's when I realized I I
gotta start talking about this I gotta
tell people what's going on what I'm
seeing in the environment how how the
habitat of these sharks is completely
destroyed how they have no more food
sources and and the fact that
in the midst of all this people are
still going out and collecting Jaws as
trophies
I I don't um I don't know how this is
all going to change but I know that it's
it's incumbent upon me who has seen
these things you know to be the canary
in the coal mine and say hey this is
happening are you aware
if you like what you hear and you want
to support more content like this please
rate and review us in your podcast app
and consider a National Geographic
subscription that's the best way to
support overheard go to Nat geo.com
Explore More to subscribe and hey for
more on Gibbs journey in his research
check out our story about him online
we've also got an article about how
great whites change their color to sneak
up on prey plus you can watch Gibbs in a
National Geographic documentary camo
sharks he and other scientists try to
catch sharks in the middle of their
color changes
and if you just can't get enough sharks
we got a whole bunch of shark vest
stories for you including how drones are
changing how we observe and think about
sharks that's all in your show notes
right there in your podcast app
[Music]
this week's overheard episode is
produced by Alana Strauss our other
producers Kyrie Douglas our senior
producers are Brian Gutierrez and Jacob
penter our senior editor is Eli Chen our
manager of audio is Carla Wills our
executive producer of audio is Devar
artalon the photo editor is Julie Howe
Ted Woods sound design this episode and
hansdale Sue composed our theme music
this podcast is a production of National
Geographic partners the National
Geographic Society committed to
illuminating and protecting The Wonder
of our world funds the work of National
Geographic Explorer Gibbs kaguru Michael
Tribble is the vice president of
integrated storytelling Nathan lump is
National Geographic's editor-in-chief
and I'm your host Peter Gwen thanks for
listening and see y'all next time
[Music]
[Music]
thank you